Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to I hope
I pronouncing that correctly. Is it Comey
from Missouri? Q May.
Speaker 3: Comey.
Speaker 1: You're muted, Komi. You have
to unmute yourself. I've unmuted you,
but unless there this call.
Speaker 3: I was calm. Sorry.
Speaker 1: Calm. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: I've come to call in about why
yesterday's January six committee findings. Okay.
Speaker 1: You just cut out.
Speaker 3: Oh, I cut out. Mm hmm.
Speaker 1: Mm hmm. All right. Go ahead,
Watts. See if you can get the question in.
Speaker 3:
Okay. So according to the sixth committee,
the Turner Diaries was used in the planning
of the assault on the Capitol. If you
don't know, it's the neo-Nazi manifesto
used by the far right in many cases
of terrorism like Oklahoma City. Yep.
And do you think there's a possibility that they
could cause, like an eventual rise of the far
right or set off in the future that.
Speaker 1: What would cause
that? The Turner Diaries?
Speaker 3: No, just casual
insertion of white supremacist talking points.
Speaker 1: Oh, you know, I don't expect. No,
I don't. I don't think so. I don't that's not
a major I have many, many different concerns,
but I can't say that that's one of them.
Speaker 3: I mean, you have Tucker Carlson
at Fox News pulling the strings
inserted into great replacement.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, that's true. I mean,
I guess I guess it depends on whether you
consider all of these things part of the same
movement or not. But I mean. Yeah, but listen,
maybe I guess I just don't think about things
in those terms. If people like Tucker and others
start and they have been sort of weaponizing
these ideas, they're putting their own spin on
them and making them sort of something new and of
themselves, even though it's linked to something
else. So. Yeah. I mean, I guess to some degree,
but I don't necessarily see things as so kind of
siloed and black and white.
Speaker 3: As they move
here in Missouri, or do we have to deal with a
barrage of anti-trans laws? Yes. Hypocritically.
One of them was found to be a child molester.
Speaker 1: One of the people pushing the laws.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Oh, that's not
surprised. That's old hat. That. That's. That's.
It would be surprising if that wasn't the case.
Speaker 3: True. Every conservative
accusation was a confession. Yeah.
Speaker 1: It is. It's incredible. I
mean, I haven't heard of the specific one,
but we've seen that all over the country.
Speaker 3: And also the groomer accusations
are getting pretty violent, like proud boys
attacking drag queen story hours and some
people bringing long arms to Disney World.
Speaker 1: It's an insane, insane world out
there. It's crazy.
Speaker 3:
It is.
Speaker 1: All
right. Well, thank you for the
call. I really appreciate it.
Speaker 3: You're welcome.
Speaker 1: All right. There we
go. Always great to hear from people
from Missouri. Very, very important